il est à peine 9 heures du matin il
pleut à boire debout
milla fils commence ici juste devant le
bureau du président poutine à moscou
et elle fait tout le tour du bloc
millions mais lansing jeune femme a au
contraire décidé
or à 1000m 6
ces hommes et femmes portent dans leurs
bras l'espoir et la colère de tout un
peuple
une pétition qui a fait le tour du pays
du jamais vu aux russes qui endian et
moi poutine doit reculer maintenant la
stabilité politique et sociale qui en
dépend du programme go to reason to stop
car dans un pays où presque la moitié
des hommes vivent jusqu'à 65 ans
seulement
relever l'âge de la retraite est perçu
comme une insulte et un affront mr
president is votre visite aux arômes
très politique
les échos sacha et sa femme anna où tous
les du 39 ans c'est la toute première
fois de leur vie qu'ils s'aiment tête au
gouvernement pour défendre un droit
qu'il considère sa clique
ils ont deux enfants y la retraite à 60
ans sacha et et mordicus même si elle
sera maigre quelques centaines de
dollars par mois
heureusement nous savons très bien que
les hommes vivent moins longtemps que
les femmes et c'est fort possible que je
ne puisse jamais touché à un seul chèque
explique sa charge
c'est humiliant que nous fait le
gouvernement ajoute en réalité c'est que
la majorité des retraités continuent de
travailler ici la retraite est un
complément de revenus essentielle
samassa leur releveur boris kagarlitski
c est lui aussi aux privilèges de sa
retraite imminente mille sociologue voit
dans la gronde populaire un ras-le-bol
qui va au delà de la réforme les ressent
vraiment trop les rangs mais il ya des
limites
on a toléré poutine on entend les
révolutions tout le monde comprend
maintenant qu'il faut changer le système
politique avant que chargé de refondre
ancêtres et russe
[Applaudissements]
depuis des mois les manifestations se
multiplient et s'intensifient de moscou
à vladivostok
mais aussi dans les petits villages
autrefois silencieux ou poutine y est
adulé depuis 18 ans je pense que c'est
un chose absolument nouvelle existait
n'était pas possible il ya deux ans
trois ans nous devrons dire finalement
que se mènent deux guerres mandat de
poutine et que poutine et son entourage
voulait utiliser le donné mandat pour
tous pour faire tous les choses qu'on a
peur peur de faire avant mais à quel
prix se demande anne à qui sait très
bien que la pétition qu'elles portent à
bout de bras ne changera probablement
rien et elle craint la suite un
soulèvement populaire comme en ukraine
dit elle et elle n'est pas la seule
quite les rustres ont été silencieux dit
il mais ne pourront pas le rester
éternellement ici tamar alter escaut
radio canada